- I don't know how this became my life,
but D-Rock just woke
me up on a text saying
we need a question of
the day for the vlog so,
A. Fuck me,
B. Question of the day.
♫ We're unstoppable
Hey guys, I'm sitting here
at the airport in Hong Kong
on my way to Singapore.
Wanted to tell you about
a keynote I gave in Utah
for my homie Shawn Doris at VidSummit.
Real good stuff.
- [D-Rock] Yeah.
- Um, this is really made for everybody,
actually this could be
one of the more valuable
DailyVees because if you
consume my content on YouTube
a lot of you have aspirations to succeed
in the YouTube environment.
And this was clearly, and I mean clearly,
a creator's oriented talk.
When I give talks, a lot
of my talks right now
are about marketing and
businesses leveraging
the current state of attention.
This was a very different talk,
a very different Q & A.
Had some good moments--
- [D-Rock] The Q & A was incredible.
- The Q & A's, D-Rock,
the Q & A's are always incredible right?
- Yes.
- Sitting here, actually laying here
on the flight from Hong Kong to Singapore.
Pretty dark out there.
Anyway, just jammin' on my email.
Hustlin', tryin' to get some questions.
That's it.
- [D-Rock] I need to go now.
- I've gotta prep for
this call in two minutes.
- [D-Rock] Oh that's
right, you have a call.
- I work D-Rock.
(laughs)
- [Woman] Oh really?
- Uh, gotta have some fun on
these fuckin' 24 hour flights,
or travel schedules.
Anyway, nonetheless,
this is a standout episode for anybody
who wants to become a creator,
become a YouTube channel.
Take advantage of the current state,
and really this is a interesting keynote
that sets up Crushing It, my
book coming out in January.
And so I hope you enjoy it.
- You can put the link right down there.
- Oh, we can put a link.
Oh we haven't, you know what,
we have not filmed the
Amazon right hook yet.
You know why, because
I'm very focused on this.
We've been very focused--
Pointing at D-Rock?
Let's just, there we go.
But, soon we will do the
Crushing It book push.
Anyway, watch this keynote.
- [Man] Alright, enjoy
your Gary V. time guys.
Gary, you need a mic?
- I think I'm mic'd, so I
think I'm good thank you.
- [Man] Okay, you just,
let me know if you need anything.
- I appreciate it.
Hey.
It's great to see all of you.
Really excited to be
here and really excited
to focus on a couple of different things.
So, I really want to go into Q & A,
so where are the mics?
I just want to get a sense
of where the mics are.
Do we have runners?
Or do you have guys have--
They're gonna be in the aisle?
Okay, cool.
So, feel free to jump up at any point
and get into the Q & A.
I mean, really from my standpoint
this is a super unique kind of conference
because there is so many people here
that I know, have known for a long time,
back in the day, have watched from afar,
cheer for to be successful,
and I think it's a super interesting time
for this conference to be thrown.
Because I think for a lot of you,
for a lot of you,
there's an intuitive understanding
that we're in a moment in time, right?
For me, I've been very lucky.
I think I trade on moments in time.
I knew in 1996, seven,
that this internet thing
was gonna be something,
and my dad's liquor store
had to take advantage of it.
I knew that this email thing blew my--
I mean, there's a lot
of youngsters in here.
How many people here
were on email in 1997?
Raise your hand.
Awesome.
So, a lot.
Fuck, okay.
(audience laughs)
You know I had 91% open rates
on Wine Library's email
service in 1997, '98.
And that was me selling wine
on this new thing called email,
that didn't cost me
money to make a catalog
to send it in the mail.
And it was instantaneous
the second the wine
came into the store, it was out the door.
It might be tough for people to understand
how holy fuck that was.
And it's basically the
same way I feel about
this entire audience
right now in this moment.
You know, the influencer thing
has been around a long time.
You know like, when I first met QPark
in my office, like six, seven years ago,
and telling all these Vine kids,
like, "You're gonna be famous."
Like, "This is real."
I remember their feedback
to me was very much like,
"Are you sure?"
Some of them were like, "Yeah."
But not to the level I think
that I spoke to the conviction.
It was only because I'd already lived
that three, four years earlier.
I started a YouTube channel in 2006.
Right, my wine show was there.
And that was on the back end of watching
what happened with bloggers.
Before video was even a thing online.
Or podcasts the first
time it meant something.
Not this new iteration.
This the same old game forever.
And the biggest thing
that I want to get across
to every every single
person here is regret.
My entire talk right now
is gonna be about regret.
And let me explain what I mean by that.
I'm not sure that was worth
a whoo, but I'll take it.
(audience laughs)
It is my intuition,
that if you don't squeeze the opportunity
that's in front of all of us right now
as hard as you fucking
can, you will have regret.
If you are smart enough, and aware enough,
to even be here today,
you were ready ahead of 99%
of the players in our society.
I do not believe that people in this room
are quantifying the fact they
even know this world exists,
and are willing to take the financial
and time allocation to be here.
How big of an advantage that is,
how far along you actually are.
Because when you're in the system,
it feels like everybody's doing it.
You're amongst yourselves.
The same way it felt like
in 2006 and seven for me
with Twitter and Facebook.
Like, we all knew social
media, but the world didn't.
The influencers have the leverage.
You have the leverage.
If you're paying attention to
what's going on in the world
of media consumption right now,
there are more buyers
of content than ever.
Facebook, and Amazon, and Google, and Hulu
are gonna bid for the NFL and the NBA.
We are not down to three
media companies anymore.
If you understand how the
chess plays out in this game,
the only thing that you need to make sure,
is that you don't believe so much
in the thing that got you here,
that you stay on it too long.
The vulnerability to
this room, is one thing,
you figure out YouTube, or Facebook Watch,
or Instagram, or Snapchat,
or something else.
You win, and then you never innovate.
And then when that platform declines,
you decline with it.
As long as everybody here is religious,
around creating and innovating,
in every channel as it evolves,
and you stay in the yes business.
How many people here are
with brands or agencies?
Raise your hand.
Great, so for you guys and gals,
it's about understanding how under-priced
this opportunity is for brands right now.
Right?
And just following where
the under-priced nature is.
YouTube influencers,
when I was buying them
in 2007, eight and nine,
were really fuckin' cheap.
Right?
They were tens of dollars, for free stuff.
Not hundreds, not thousands,
not tens of thousands and
not hundreds of thousands.
And basically very
honestly, I have one pitch.
It's the same one.
It's just pattern recognition.
Where is the attention
of the end consumer?
And where do people think it's
over-priced or under-priced?
Why do companies and
organizations spend millions
and tens of millions of dollars
to produce television and film?
And brands spend to sponsor it?
And what's that worth?
Versus me throwing dollars towards many
of the faces in this room.
Even at numbers that they
can't believe they now get.
I still deem as grossly under-priced
for what it is they get in
return as of this moment.
Even the top YouTubers
and Instagram celebrities
I think are grossly
under-priced most of the time
for what they give in return.
Which is unbelievable levels of awareness,
and relevancy in the world
that we live in right now.
I live in a world in my brain
that this is the only thing that matters,
and basically nothing else does.
I don't even own a fucking computer.
Like this is it.
I run a $200 million media
company, I live my life.
I have not had a laptop
for a year and a half.
I actually had to do something
the other day on a laptop,
and it was not like riding a bike.
I was like, what the fuck?
You know?
(audience laughs)
When you understand that this is it,
that this is the remote
control of our lives,
and that 50% of the time
spent on this device,
is on a platform that delivers content,
A.K.A. a social network.
It starts getting real serious, real fast.
And I just wanna remind
everybody, it's not going back.
This is only going to evolve forward.
So, I guess the thing that
I really wanna get across,
A. Is I wanna really do Q & A,
'cause I wanna answer
people's direct question.
Because you can see my
pontificating anywhere you want,
anytime you want, somewhere on the web.
So please take advantage of that.
And B. I've watched this
over, and over and over again.
I did it, Q did it.
We have these moments
when we have leadership,
and then we let it get away from us
because we take for granted.
And then we look back, and we regret.
I had leadership in YouTube and Twitter.
I left YouTube for six years,
went on Viddler, did other things,
like ran a wine business.
Like, this is what I'm most worried about.
That you know it, that you're right.
You're here right now,
and you're either not working hard enough,
or not believing enough in
how right you actually are.
And so when I really
thought about the talk
that I would give here
amongst everybody else,
I just was like, "Fuck I'm gonna suffocate
"the shit out of everybody."
(audience chuckles)
In a very positive way.
(audience laughs)
So that they understand like,
please, please, please,
don't look back at this
talk in three years
and be like, "Fuck, I
wish I'd listened to him,
"and I wish I did a little more work,
"created a little more content,
"took it a little bit more serious."
Because for the last decade
of this distribution disruption,
that the internet has done to our society,
there have been people that
have stumbled into the moment
that you're in right now.
You're here.
And just don't realize
how far ahead they are,
because you're stuck
being used to each other.
98% of America has no idea
what the fuck is going on in here.
(audience laughs)
That is our opportunity.
And so, I think that we need
to really take a step back
and start thinking about a couple things.
Number one, context is
much more of a factor
for your life than people talk about.
We talk so much about
content and storytelling,
and that's great,
but the lack of context that
I see from so many of you,
you take a piece of content and you think,
just posting it everywhere,
it's going to be successful,
is a huge mistake.
Please do not use all
the social media channels as distribution.
Think smartly how to make
native content within them.
In the same way that you're
gonna act differently here
than you will with your parents at dinner,
than you will with your
buddies on a weekend in Vegas,
than you will in a business meeting
with the biggest CEO in the world.
You're still you, but
you're slightly different
in all those environments.
Your content can't be successful
on Facebook and YouTube the same way
'cause they're different platforms.
There is not enough
religion around us creators,
around context of the platform.
Too much is being put just on the content,
and that is a very important variable.
Very, very important.
So please think about that.
Two, in a world where
there's a lot of people
that should stand up here and
give the presentation over me,
when it comes to
thumbnails, and headlines,
and what I would call "growth hacking".
A. It's super important,
but I feel like everybody here
is either grounded in it,
or knows it's importance,
and will continue to try
to learn those tactics.
The one thing that I'm
seeing from a lot creators
in this room specifically,
and outside, similar to a
lot of the creators in here,
is that you're getting
so growth hack oriented
that it's manipulating and
diluting the actual story.
And it's just about hacking
and getting the numbers,
which is great for the short term.
But is the reason so many people
have lost in the long term
because they become mathematical machines,
and their story becomes less authentic.
And they become a
caricature of themselves,
that are basically pandering to the growth
in the category they
wanna be successful in.
This has been the single reason
I feel like I've had continuous success,
because I just stay kind of in my thing,
and if it works at the time at YouTube,
or Instagram or Snapchat, mazel tov.
And if it doesn't, I'm okay with that.
I'm okay with people
having more followers,
or making more money.
Because I know when I deviate,
you have only a chapter
instead of an entire career.
So I implore so many of you,
I understand especially,
shit, hanging out with everybody here.
It's like, "Oh, you have four
million fuckin' subscribers?"
Like, you know all that shit, I get it.
It gets very competitive, we're humans.
I get it.
But please do me a favor,
please, please, please,
be religious to hold onto
your truths and your stories.
Because when you start diluting from that,
you start beginning the process
of you becoming irrelevant.
It's important.
You like that one?
It's good right?
(audience applauds)
Got an interesting one,
that I thought would be a
good theme for everybody.
We need to ask more.
I get so many emails and
DMs from so many of you,
of like, how.
The answer is, ask more.
How do you get brand deals?
Email every brand on earth.
(audience laughs)
I mean this.
You know, I know some of you have seen,
like me talk about Instagram DM.
Like I'm getting 50 emails a week,
from people, that same basic title.
Doing the Instagram DM
changed my fuckin' life.
A stunning thing happens when you ask.
Somebody says yes.
So, I think one of the biggest things
that is happening in this
room when I think about it,
is that people's egos
are getting in their way.
The feelings of getting
hurt when somebody says no,
hurts your ego so much that it stops you
from even asking in the first place.
It is stunning to me how much
I like when people say no.
I prefer when people say no.
I tend to bounce into
different industries,
in my career, because
once I become big in one,
and it becomes easy to yes, I hate it.
So, there's a lot of
fuckin' fancy people in here
who think they're bigger
than they actually are.
(audience laughs)
And so I highly recommend,
that you check your
fuckin' ego at the door
because it's the substantial aspect
that's holding you back
from your next chapter.
So, please, please,
please start asking more.
More DM, more email.
And, 51-49.
When you're reaching out to somebody
that you want something from,
it's a good idea to start with
what you're gonna do for them.
I'm aware that you won
a $100,000 sneaker deal.
I get it.
The fuck's in it for the sneaker?
Right?
So don't take for granted
subscribers or comments.
Be thoughtful, understand
what they're about,
pay attention, do your homework, listen,
pay attention to what
they're doing on social.
30 minutes of homework can articulate
a far better way to have a conversation
with somebody that you
want something from.
(light audience applause)
Thanks mom.
(audience laughs)
Distribution.
Do not become completely vulnerable
to YouTube or Facebook.
This is imperative.
This is super duper one
of the biggest things
that people make a mistake of.
Win there, but always
have 20% of your energy
on testing new things,
even when you feel you
don't have any more time
'cause you're working
so hard to do the thing.
Because, the reality is,
all I'm doing right now,
if you go back and watch this talk,
all I'm doing right now is systematically
breaking down the things that I've watched
for the last 10 years,
that have stopped people from succeeding.
It's all these little subtle things
that I'm dropping on you now,
these are the things that
stop you from succeeding,
which is what I spend
all my time on, right?
Stop the vulnerabilities.
All of us are on a boat,
with a bunch of holes,
and you're just putting
your finger in all of them.
I'm just trying to give
you the cliché ones,
that I and all of you are going through,
and it's just universal
and it will be forever.
One of the great things is, listen,
especially for this group,
YouTube, and Facebook and Instagram,
these are just imperative monsters.
Until they're not.
And, what has been stunning to me--
For example, here is
something stunning to me.
It is stunning to me of how
smart this room is, right?
I just said, look 98%
doesn't know you're here.
You know like, this is real in here.
And, how many of you have
stopped doing Snapchat?
Like, I laugh at your lack of skill.
And here's what I mean
by that harsh statement.
Most, under 30 year olds
are living on Snapchat.
One way or the other.
The data's very clear.
It's not like, you know
you could be sitting there,
and be like, "Not true,
me and my three friends
"aren't on it anymore."
That's nice Karen.
(audience laughs)
I'm talking about big data.
I'm talking about the user numbers.
I don't give a fuck
that you don't anymore,
or your neighbor said something,
or the 13 year old girl down
the street said it's dead.
I don't give a fuck.
I care about the macro data,
and the macro data shows very clearly
that there is hundreds of millions
of fuckers on this platform.
And just because Instagram
stole it's features,
which by the way, they
didn't steal their features,
features are not IP, that's business.
Everybody here stole a
ton of shit from Casey.
(audience laughs)
And so, it's not about stealing.
It's about features, great.
But there's a huge--
I'm giving you little tidbits,
there's a huge opportunity
for so many of you,
'cause I live on supply
and demand of attention.
And when a lot of people left Snapchat
to only focus on Instagram Stories,
'cause, why should I do two things?
It's easier to do one.
Or whatever other fancy
reason you made up that call,
it left a white space
for enormous opportunity
and I highly recommend
Shonduras comes outta retirement
and starts drawing again.
And, a million other things.
And so, these are the
things that fascinate me.
Becoming too one dimensional,
not creating content
native for the platform
and the thing that most is
running through my mind,
which is, I'm trying to get
into the mind of this audience.
When you have the ambition,
A.K.A. the audacity,
to have your living be you just living,
not having enough time is not an excuse.
The people that have been
sitting here and saying like,
"Well how the fuck am I?
"You know I'm already--"
You, want to get paid
hundreds of thousands,
and or millions of dollars a year,
running around the earth.
(audience laughs)
You have to quantify how amazing that is.
It's obnoxious that it's
actually a real thing.
If you go read the Amazon reviews
of my first book Crush It,
that came out in 2009 where
I talked about all this,
people are like, "Get
the fuck out of here.
"Nobody's gonna pay people to like,
"do things on a device."
Like, it was so ridi--
That's only eight years ago.
Right?
So please, please understand
the obnoxious level of
audacity that we have
to be interesting enough
to get paid to just do.
And please then deploy the work ethic
that is needed to actually pull this off.
The biggest fear I have is for the people
that are actually having success.
Because complacency kicks in,
and you just get into pattern recognition.
There's a lot of you
here that are winning.
And, the thing that I'm
really most passionate about
is making sure you're
challenging yourself.
There's so much more to
do with what you're doing.
But it's only gonna be incremental.
You're only gonna get paid
a little more to speak.
You're only gonna sell
a little more merch.
You're only gonna get a
bigger deal a little bit more.
It's still being creative.
Like, to me one of the big things
with video creators that I'm
really trying to challenge
is to start paying attention
to voice a lot more.
I think a lot of you, and
again I know a lot of you,
and I've watched a lot of people
that used the hashtag last night and,
thanks for the dude
that offered me a drink.
You know, but I wasn't here.
You know, a lot of you when
I went down the rabbit hole
on my flight yesterday
just to get a sense,
so many of you could be so
successful in podcast form.
But you haven't even gone there.
So many of you could create
such an incredible Alexa skill,
or an Alexa briefing that can change
the opportunity for you.
Guys, as somebody who was
there from day one of YouTube,
YouTube is mature.
Instagram is mature.
The next land grabs,
the things that get you from zero to hero,
are staring you directly
in the face right now.
The problem is, some level of your success
is stopping you from allocating time
to take the chance on the new thing
that can disproportionately leap frog you
three or four spots.
So, please let's keep
challenging ourselves.
Please let's understand what's
actually happening here.
Please understand how much
of a ridiculous advantage
you have right now,
and how much more you need to squeeze.
Please understand every
13 year old in the world
wants to be you,
so supply and demand is coming.
Everybody is gonna do this,
which means you gotta be
disproportionately better
in the next year or two.
So, just like coders and
developers got paid a lot
and right now all their parents
want their kids to be developers,
which means, it's actually
gonna be commoditized,
and they're gonna get paid a lot less.
Same for us.
There's not a 15 year old
in this fuckin' country
that doesn't have this job
as one of their first one
or two things they wanna do.
Which means, it's going to be harder,
because the brands, and
the AdSense and the merch
is gonna get split
between 83 million people
instead of 8.3 million people.
Got it?
And you're only so cute
and charismatic, Shonduras.
(audience laughs)
So, that's the state of
the union of this space.
I would love for people to
start lining up for questions
'cause I'd like to get into more detail.
So please do that, and when I see enough,
good, looks like we're
gonna get there quickly,
we'll get into it.
And, I know a lot of you came out
for this event because I talked about it
and I saw a lot of the
tweets ahead of time.
And I just want you guys to
know I'm ridiculously humbled
and thankful for the
attention and the admiration.
And I really, really, really, really,
have a lot of heart for this community.
And, I thank you for having me.
Thanks.
(audience applauds)
Okay, let's get into the good shit.
- First of all thank you,
and I know you've inspired
a bunch of us here.
Um, you talk about regret,
and you talk about not doing shit.
And I'm here, I'm a small guy.
I own two small businesses
in Austin, Texas.
I wanna get better.
I know that this is an
opportunity to be first in line
with about 800 people.
I'll do whatever I have
to do to go to New York.
Even if it's scrub your
floors with my toothbrush.
Is that at all a possibility?
- Well you could definitely come
and scrub our floors with a toothbrush.
- Okay.
(audience laughs)
- What's the second part?
- The second part is I
just wanna get better
and I know by doing that I
have to learn from the best.
I've been following you.
I don't even wanna follow you,
I just wanna follow your team.
I'm a creator, and I'm
just asking for that.
- Cool, so right, do me a favor.
Email gary@vaynermedia.
- Yes sir.
- In the title, put I'm Ryan,
I'm the first guy that
talked at the event today.
I talked about toothbrush,
this, that, the other thing.
And, in January I'll let you come
and spend a week with the team.
- [Ryan] Thank you sir.
- You're welcome.
- [Ryan] Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- Mr. Gary sir thank you.
- [Gary] How are you doing?
- I am awesome.
- [Gary] Good man.
- I watched your video about
a year and a half ago or so,
and my channel has less
than 400 subscribers.
But I hit it with--
- [Gary] 400 more than zero.
- Yeah, that's true.
I hit it with depth,
'cause I heard you talkin'
about depth versus width.
And that alone allowed me to make
over a quarter million
dollars just within my niche.
So, my question to you is--
- And real quick, I'm gonna
stop you, I apologize.
This is super important.
So many people are so caught up in width,
and Eliah did a good job
and understood depth.
Like, there are so many people
that have so many more followers than me.
And their book comes out,
and they sell 1,000 copies.
Or, when they're the
headliner of a conference,
half the people show up that is expected
'cause how many followers they have.
Which doesn't allow them to command
the price they want for speaking.
Or when they make merch,
'cause Logan and Jake are making a lot.
They sell a lot less.
Depth is massively important
and the number one issue in this room
is the way you're taking
your audience for granted.
The amount of you that
I audited yesterday,
that have never replied to a comment,
in YouTube or Instagram,
is baffling and utterly disappointing.
- [Man] Right on.
- Right on is right.
- [Man] Preach it brother.
- It's real, you know.
Because at some level, you know,
it's one thing if you want
fame or the perception of fame
and that gets you off,
and like great, do it.
Then you should be about the numbers.
But so many of you here want
to pay your college debt off,
or live the life that you want,
or make generational wealth
that your grandkids have.
It's gonna be about the depth.
Dude's got 400 fuckin'
subscribers, made $250,000.
Now maybe what he was selling
or have you is different,
I get it, but that needs to be something
that people wrap their head around.
I'm just stunned.
Like everyday, everyday I get
comments from people like,
"I can't believe you reply."
Or, "How much time you
put into your audience."
And every single time I
get that, I say to myself,
I can't believe how much you guys don't.
- I just wanna say
again thank you so much.
Also some of the people that
I work with, my clients,
they are your followers too.
It'll be super awesome if I
could take a picture with you.
- [Gary] For sure.
- Would it be possible for me to come up
on the stage and do that?
- Sure.
- Thank you sir.
- You got it.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you Gary.
- You're welcome bro.
- Oh, gotta turn it around.
- I've heard.
(audience laughs)
- If you could press the
button for me? Thank you sir.
- Got it.
- Gary, thank you.
- Take care.
What's up my man?
- Gary my brother, thank you so much.
Consumed a lot of your content,
and it's really shaped a large portion
of how we're running
our business right now.
So, thank you.
- [Gary] You're welcome.
- My question, we are a
jump rope fitness company.
So you type in jump rope into YouTube,
jump rope, it's just all us.
We basically own that niche.
- [Gary] Love it, okay.
- And so, we're thinkin'
long term for a business.
Are we better off, really,
we're already sellin' jump ropes,
so we basically own the information
around people who wanna buy jump ropes.
Should we keep going into
just selling jump ropes
and jump rope digital products?
Or, how do you feel
about brand integrations?
Advertising on our videos?
Like for us, sometimes for
us sometimes it feels like
let's turn advertisements off.
- I've got a great answer for you.
Yeah, yeah I get it.
So, expansion is when brands get diluted.
So, for the first question
I would ask you is,
how much revenue is your
jump rope business doing?
And how big is the overall
jump rope business industry?
How long have you had the company?
- Two years.
- Right, my intuition
is you still don't have
a big enough portion
of the jump rope world.
And so probably there's
a lot more to expand
before you go into other things.
But this is back to why I--
You know, I couldn't have gotten luckier
with the two questions in a row.
So cool, I just got off
my high horse of saying
I communicate with you and engage, right?
And like, made you feel
bad that you don't.
What's really scary is, I
do it 'cause I'm selfish.
The reason I engage with all of you
is 'cause I read everything you say
so that I can get better
insights to what to do next.
So, your answer to your question,
like I'm super smart, fine.
Your community will tell you.
You just need to ask.
I mean it man, the answer is
literally in your comments.
You've just gotta take the
18 hours of fuckin' asking.
- Alright, appreciate
it brother thank you.
- [Gary] You got it, you got it.
- Gary!
- [Gary] Yo!
- What's up man?
Danny Gould, Selling Silicon Valley.
We chatted at Relentless.
- [Gary] I remember.
- Yeah, I asked you the question,
on a macro scale how to drive
my real estate vlog, right?
- [Gary] I remember.
- But now I wanna ask you about the micro.
- [Gary] Okay.
- The local.
Because, for me right now,
you know, obviously Silicon Valley.
Right, there's a lot of baby
boomers, a lot of older--
- [Gary] I'm looking at
something to answer your question
so keep going.
- Yeah, totally.
A lot of older folks.
- [Gary] Yes.
- Right?
- Who, obviously when you sell real estate
you have to list to last, right?
So getting these sellers
to engage with content,
or to viewing.
Right?
- [Gary] I'm listening.
- So, in terms of the older generation.
A lot of these people aren't
on some of these platforms
that we're talking about, right.
- [Gary] Yup.
- So, how do I--
'Cause I'm comin' to you
because I've thought about this
for a long time.
How would you recommend--
- [Gary] Selling homes to older people?
- Well no, no, no.
Getting in front of these older people
on the digital platform.
- So look, he's generalizing,
don't beat him up.
(audience laughs)
- [Man] I know, but like, you know?
- So look, I think to both of your points,
you're both right.
He's right.
There is not a high usage of
60 to 80 year olds on Snapchat.
That's just real data, you know?
And so, couple things.
Number one, Facebook
does not have that issue.
When I look at conversion on Facebook,
55 to 70 year old conversions on Facebook
are just incredible.
There's so much attention,
there's so much scale.
They're going through it more carefully.
And I'm a very big fan.
So if you haven't run five mile radius's
from your open houses on
Facebook to that demo,
of 50 to 75 year olds,
or 35 to 75 year olds,
with hundred thousand
income levels or greater.
Have you run Facebook ads
aggressively against that?
- [Danny] I have.
- So then, the issue is your creative.
You know, like I'm gonna
leave here right now
and go to a Berkshire
Hathaway real estate pitch
for Vayner.
- [Danny] That's us.
- And the data's very clear.
So, I think first you have
to look at your creative.
Right?
Like, is your creative hitting the note?
If you're in it, you know
the issue with real estate.
There's a lot of people at high net worth
that are gonna look at you and say
you're too young and
inexperienced and not go with you.
I lived it my whole life.
Now I'm finally going to the other side,
so it kinda fuckin' sucks but, you know.
(audience laughs)
I get it.
I understand that.
So that's one thing to look at.
I'd also highly recommend you going
down the rabbit hole of Next Door.
So have you looked at Next Door?
- [Danny] I have yes.
- So I'm super intrigued by that platform
from a real estate standpoint.
I think there's super
hardcore opportunity,
and then finally if I were you,
I would do, the third thing is,
I would put 50% of my
energy, if you want them,
to go old school and
door to door direct mail.
You know, just 'cause this is happening
doesn't mean we need to force
everybody into that behavior.
I never give a fuck what you're doing.
I'm just trying to figure
out what you're doing.
You know?
I don't have any horse in the race
whether you do VR, or
Snapchat or Vine, you know.
Q and I loved Vine, but then it changed.
Like I don't know, it is what it is.
Fuck it.
So, I would spend a lot
more time in traditional
than you probably are.
- [Danny] Cool, thanks Gary.
- Cool, you got it.
Hey man.
- How's it going Gary?
- [Gary] Really well.
- So, when looking to dissect
a new social media platform
to figure out how to be successful,
what are some big picture
and practical tips
you can use to dissect that?
- Big picture is I would download
every social network that appears
on the top 150 free apps
in America every time.
Create a user name, and start tasting it.
And then, micro picture is
start creating content for it
and use your other social
channels to drive people to it
to see what happens.
So like, how many people
here are trying to figure out
what to do with Marco Polo?
You know?
Hey, so like, that's interesting.
What is happening there?
How are you using it?
Can you get 50 of your users
to be part of a group with you there?
So, big picture Zane is like,
literally wake up every morning
and look at the top 150
apps in the app store.
Pick the three or four new social networks
that come every quarter, every year.
Download them, create your account,
start making content and
then go to the channels
that you have audience
and drive them there,
and test and learn,.
Look, somebody landed here
eventually way back when
and looked at a bush
with some berries on it.
Right?
What was the strategy?
Somebody ate it.
Some dudes died, others
found strawberries.
(audience laughs)
And so that's what you have to
do with new social networks.
Social Cam took a lot of my time.
Social Cam took a lot of my time in 2011.
Anybody remember Social
Cam in that five minutes?
Right?
Five minutes.
It was number one, it was like the thing.
It came and went in like three months.
I put a lot of effort
to build audience there.
It failed, but what I learned
about mobile video on Social Cam,
became the reason that I
was able to be successful
at Vine, and Snapchat and Instagram.
And I wasn't even successful
as a creator on Vine.
I just got close to the
creators that were successful.
But then, without that
Social Cam three months,
I wouldn't have had the IP
of the dynamics of video
in that environment to make me successful.
I highly recommend, so many of
you were in the no business.
I don't need another social network.
It's gonna take away
from what I'm focused on.
What if it goes in and
out of fashion fast?
What if it's the next Vine?
It doesn't matters.
What matters is the IP and the learning
and the land grab while it's there.
If Monkey is big for three
weeks, you can do damage there.
Got it?
That's the answer Zane.
- Hey Gary.
- Hey Jay.
- Two things, one I saw you a
couple years ago in New York
and your fitness plan's workin'
for ya, you're lookin' good.
- [Gary] Thanks brother.
- Two is, I have run a digital
agency since I was young.
I started it when I was 17,
it's grown year over year for 20 years.
We cut our teeth on websites,
but I've got this gut
feeling that websites
are kinda becoming billboards.
And, so the last six to 12 months,
and we're in Northeast Florida--
- That being said, that being said Jay,
guys, actually it's
weird that you said that.
Yes, but.
I actually think one of
the biggest vulnerabilities
in this entire audience collectively,
is the lack of a proper website
collecting first party data
that you can re-market to.
Everybody is living so,
on all these platforms,
they're not driving to their own domain
where they're capturing--
I mean, my email list does damage.
You know, it may not be
what email was years ago,
but I've been trying to
make it better and better,
and it sucked for awhile.
But now we've figured out, like fuck,
really give exclusive content,
like really make it good.
And it does damage.
So yes, but ironically
the amount of people here
who should have a
Squarespace, or an about.me,
or build a Wordpress for
themselves, and own their url,
is quite high.
- Yeah it's interesting,
so the website is kind
of still the hub for us
but we're working kinda building
the spokes outta the wheel.
And um, probably in the
last 12 months or so,
we've really started to pivot a lot harder
towards video, marketing, communication
and all those kind of things.
A lot of it thanks to you.
We're in Northeast Florida,
so technologically-wise,
it's not New York City,
it's not San Francisco.
It's that kinda thing.
So, if you're me, you've
got a 12 person team.
You're growing, but you're
looking to the future.
Where are you going?
What are you focused on?
- Voice.
- [Jay] Okay.
- If I started Vayner Media today,
I would call it Vayner Voice.
And we would be an Alexa,
Google Home, Apple Pod
and podcast infrastructure shop.
Voice is the next frontier.
- [Jay] Yeah, and I
just started a podcast--
- Video, is about to
get arbitraged by voice.
Like some of your views
are about to go away.
'Cause somebody's gonna
be listening to something.
'Cause you can do two
things when you listen.
- [Jay] Yeah, and I just started
a weekly podcast actually.
Probably two months ago
thanks to that advice.
So, we'll work on it.
- I'm glad, I would go hardcore into that.
- [Jay] Okay, cool thanks Gary.
- Take care Jay.
- Hey Gary.
- [Gary] How are you?
- I'm doing well thanks, how are you?
- [Gary] Good, great.
- First of all, thank you for everything.
I've been following you for awhile
and I really appreciate it.
I have a marketing company that I started
when I was much younger.
Now we're doing web design--
- [Gary] Were you six or?
- About.
(audience laughs)
We're actually working
with some Fortune 500s now,
so we're growing and,
yeah you know one of our service lines
that's been really profitable for us
and we have a high retention rate on
is reputation management.
So I know there are some
big players out there,
and we're going up against them now.
But our retention rate is crazy high,
we're very effective at what
we do, and we're scaleable.
We've built it out in a way,
so my question for you is,
I'm really looking for ways to grow
large quantities and scale
as big as fast as possible.
- [Gary] Why?
- Because we're growing
year by year already,
and I wanna see how big I can take this,
and how quickly I can take
it as big as possible.
- [Gary] Well, let me ask you a question.
- Yeah.
- The only way you can do
that is either raise money.
- [Man] Okay.
- Or, start taking a lot
less money personally.
- [Man] Okay.
Well I've already started on the second.
- Good.
- But as far as investors,
I've been approached before,
but I'm looking for a
more strategic investor.
Someone who would know
what to do in this space.
And most people are, you
know people in real estate,
or family who see the opportunity,
but they won't be able to really help me.
- Smart money.
You want smart money.
- [Man] Are you looking to invest?
- I'm not.
- [Man] Okay.
(audience laughs)
I had to ask.
- You gotta ask, right?
- [Man] Yeah.
- Look, I think you need to
decide between smart money
and passive money.
I'm gonna give you a really
good piece of advice.
In 2001 and two, when I lived
through the business world,
and in 2007, six and eight,
when I lived through the business world,
I had a lot of friends that
were looking for smart money.
And then the market crashed,
and they were looking for money
and there was none to be had.
Just keep that in mind.
- Okay.
What would you do with the money?
Where would be the avenues you would hit?
- I don't know, it's your
fuckin' business bro.
(audience laughs)
Like all I heard from you
is you wanna get bigger faster, sooner.
I asked why, because I think usually
when people's agenda is
to get bigger, faster.
I usually know that they're in trouble.
The way to get bigger is to go slower.
- [Man] Alright, thank you.
- You got it.
I just expand on that?
Just 'cause, not to leave
him with like a change.
You know?
Everybody's in such a ru--
You know how young?
Al, how old are you bro?
- [Al] 27.
- How old?
- [Al] 27!
- That's the thing, right?
To me, his advantage is his youth.
Which should allow him
to go slower, not faster.
And I get it, everybody wants to win.
I get it.
But, I know one thing
that you guys hear from me
more than most people talk
about it, is patience.
I know it's the secret sauce.
Life is long, and when
you wanna get bigger
for the sake of bigger,
you start taking shortcuts
that lead to vulnerabilities.
So I just would keep that in mind.
Hi.
- Hey Gary, aloha.
It's an honor to be here.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- Thank you for what you do.
So, I'm a complete newbie to this space.
I was one of the 98%, I just
hopped on about two months ago.
- [Gary] Cool.
- My audience that I serve,
or I wish to serve are
entrepreneurs who like me,
who struggled to get started.
And so I'm building that
group in these platforms.
And, I don't really have much,
I'm building Instagram first.
And then from there,
then my offer would be,
whether I'm affiliate marketing something
or selling courses and whatnot.
So that's sort of my vision right now.
Where I'm also building
network marketing companies
'cause I do like network marketing.
- [Gary] Why?
- It's just leverage, I
don't know, it's for fun.
- [Gary] Okay.
- I mean, what are your thoughts on that?
- Not as much as I'm saying.
- [Woman] Okay.
- But you know, just
one man's point of view.
Just curious why.
I think the reason you like it,
is 'cause there's quicker dollars in.
- Right now there's no dollars at all.
(audience laughs)
I think I like, I don't know,
it's just an interesting little challenge
to see if we can actually
grow an organization.
- [Gary] Respect, do your thing.
Look, I think when somebody decides
to get into content and creative,
and already before they've started,
they are thinking about the monetization
of affiliate or network,
or things of that nature,
you're setup to fail.
And, so what I would tell you
to do if I had the chance,
which I do, is to take a step back,
and realize, you know,
creating content to
motivate people to start
is a crowded space.
A forever space, because
people don't act, I get it.
But, what I'm worried about as a newbie,
is this is such a cliché story.
Right?
I'm gonna build an audience,
and I'm gonna monetize it, for me.
And what happens is, before you start,
you're thinking about monetization.
Like how will it happen when it happens?
What that does is
something very interesting.
It creates the wrong kind of content.
When the seed is about
long term monetization,
the seed is corroded, and
there's an element of that
in all of the content.
No question my biggest
advantage in the marketplace
is the lack of interest
of monetizing my audience.
You need to think about that.
- Is there another angle I
should be looking at this
coming into this?
- Yeah, I think the angle is to blindly
try to bring value to the audience
whether it's information or entertainment.
And then wake up in six years
and start to then debate
what the fuck to do with it.
- [Woman] Got it, okay,
okay thank you very much.
- You're welcome.
- [Woman] I'll have to get on that.
Thank you, aloha.
- Hey Gary, so I've been watching you
for about six months now.
But over the last year and a half
I've been building an Instagram
and I've got about half
a million followers.
But since I've been watching you,
I've seen probably a triple in growth
just from implementing different things.
I've just kinda put you
on my nightstand at night
and I just kinda listen to you.
- [Gary] Thank you man, happy to be there.
(audience laughs)
- So it's really exciting for me--
- It's better than yesterday guys,
like "Listen, I listen to you all the time
"when I'm in the shower."
I'm like, cool.
(audience laughs)
- No, I can say I haven't done that yet.
But what I really wanted to ask you
is I've been building this platform
'cause I'm a firm believer
that you have to have
an audience to hear you, and I'm a singer.
Before you release something,
if you really want to create momentum.
- I agree, it's momentum,
but more importantly
you know, it's leverage.
- Yeah, and that's what
we're kinda going for
because we know you
can go into labels now.
And I feel confident if we went now
we wouldn't get as good a deal
as if we went in with
the leverage like that.
- You know what's happening
in the hip-hop space right?
Put out projects, put out mix tapes,
have leverage, have millions of followers,
and then get the kind of
deal that you think you want.
By the way, you might be
the last of the Mohicans
that even give a shit to even have a deal.
- And that's kinda, my
manager is in the audience,
I actually told him, you know,
I wanna live everyday thinking
that I'm not going to get a
deal at the end of the day.
You know what I mean?
- [Gary] So do that.
- And that's kind of the game plan.
- That's not fully where
you're at right now.
- No, but coming into this time and season
where I'm releasing my first single.
What would be your strategy?
'Cause I'm heavy on Instagram,
I'm not so much on Facebook and YouTube,
and I'm branching out.
I started doing that about a month ago.
- Do you have a Spotify
and SoundCloud now?
- I don't have either
account really set up.
This is a first time go at it.
- Well that's fuckin' crazy.
- But yeah.
- You need to do that.
Right?
And start populating it.
You know one thing that I
think is really interesting,
is populating an artist's
SoundCloud and Spotify
with content of them
speaking about their thoughts
before they launch their first song.
And then you can start siphoning--
You know, because think about it.
You're building this
audience on Instagram.
How many are on Instagram now?
- [Singer] About half a million.
- Right.
So, come three months from now, tomorrow,
whenever it drops.
It's gonna be the first time
you're gonna ask that
audience to go over there.
Whereas if you had three or four months
of getting them to go over there
with the journey of your mindset
before the launch of the first album,
you'll have a much bigger base
that will create virality
instantaneously for you
when you drop the song there.
- So you think that--
- The big thing I did with Crush It,
that was very unusual, I apologize,
but I wanna give this to everybody.
The big thing I did with Crush It
that was super unusual
for booksellers in 2008
was I pre-sold it for four
months before it came out.
The conventional wisdom back then was
you have your blowout week, right?
You go on the Today Show,
and Huffington Post,
and you push and you email.
And I asked one question
in my early meeting
with Harper Collins, which was,
do all the sales count if I
get 'em in pre-order on Amazon
that week I get them?
Or, the week the book comes out?
And they go, The week the book comes out.
So like one more time, so
if I get eight this week
and 19 next week, and 47 next week...
They're like yeah, it all counts.
So I'm like, why don't people do that?
Because we lived in a traditional world
of you go on television
and you get your orders.
That's how I'm thinking about you.
I know that artists now don't turn
their SoundCloud or Spotify into a podcast
for three months before the first song.
Which is exactly why
it's a good fuckin' idea.
- [Singer] Yeah I was gonna say,
I've never seen that
done on Spotify before.
But I've seen it done on SoundCloud--
- No that's the shit
I do, we make shit up.
(audience laughs)
- [Singer] That's what I've
been doin' for a few months
and that's how I came
up with my viral video
for fuckin' content and now--
- 100%, so that's what I would do.
- Cool, thank you.
- You're welcome.
- Hey Gary.
- Hey man.
- I'm with a small agency,
and we spend a lot of our time
trying to think of
industries and verticals
that we wanna get in
on the ground level of.
And I know you're on voice right now,
and you're talkin' about that a lot.
But going through about a year and a half
worth of your content,
you've mentioned eSports a lot.
- I'm a fan.
- But, I wanted to get your opinion
on what do you think of eSports
from a marketing standpoint?
And also from a VC standpoint?
- I think from a VC standpoint
it's super dangerous
because there's a lot
of bullshit out there.
And I think that the IP
game makers and the players
have the leverage.
And there's a lot of
people building businesses
in between that are gonna be vulnerable.
Unless they're run by
very talented people.
And they'll be not as valuable
as they're being priced.
From a marketing standpoint
I think it's grossly
under-priced attention.
And that brand should spend a fuckload
more money on eSports.
- Do you see a possibility
of an outside marketing firm
partnering with an eSports team
and just doing all their content?
Or do you think it has to be in house?
- 100%, no I think if you
guys are debating eSports
as a place to go hard at,
it will become fruitful for
you if you're good at it.
- [Bald Man] Alright, thanks man.
- You got it.
- [Bald Man] Real quick
shout-out to D-Rock.
- D-Rock.
- [Audience] D-Rock!
(audience chuckles)
- D-Rock!
- Hey Gary, how's it goin'?
- It is going super well bro.
- Well nice to meet
you, I am Parker Panel.
- Hey Parker.
- I just turned 14 years old,
and when you were my age,
what were you doing to make
money and really crush it?
(audience laughs)
- What grade are you in?
- [Parker] Eighth grade.
- So in eighth grade I started
my first real, real, real business.
In eighth grade I was making
$1,000 to $2,000 a weekend
once a month selling baseball cards
in the malls of New Jersey.
- [Parker] Awesome.
- 'Cause I don't know
if you know this bro,
but there was no internet when I was 14.
(audience laughs)
And so, you know,
it's real fuckin' easy
for you to make money.
It was much harder for us old folk.
But we got by.
- [Parker] Awesome, awesome.
Well thank you so much.
- Before you leave bro.
- [Parker] Ooh, yeah?
- What are you trying to do?
- Well you know, I'm an actor,
and I started my YouTube channel,
a few days ago was my one year.
And I do a bunch of comedy videos,
and my family, my dad's over there.
He's videoing.
- [Gary] What up, dad?
Good to see you man.
- And we travel all the time,
so were just in Dubai in the Maldives,
and I videoed my adventures there.
And I really want to entertain people
so they can get out and
kinda do what you do
and really change the world and
motivate them in a good way.
- Good for you brother, I wish you luck.
- Thank you so much.
- Take care.
(audience applauds)
- So I feel terrible
to have to follow that.
Thanks Parker.
(audience laughs)
- [Gary] Yeah, you're fucked Roberto.
- Pretty much, like
what else is new right?
So how's it goin' Gary?
- [Gary] Really well,
it's good to see you.
- Good to see you man.
So, for context I'm a
creative entrepreneur
and a lot of what I do on YouTube
is I try to help people
not be starving artists.
I try to walk them through
what I did that worked,
what I did that didn't.
Why it sucks sometimes,
and my question to you right now
is for all of those people.
It's what do you see
being the disproportionate
vulnerability for creatives
and creative entrepreneurs?
'Cause right now I know you're doing
your Vayner Creative Initiative.
You're somebody who is
in the hiring chair.
So for all the creatives out there,
for all the people whether
they're a YouTube or Snapchat,
or whether they're drawing.
Like what do you think right now--
- Is the big vulnerability?
- [Roberto] Is the big vulnerability?
What are they underestimating?
- That they're not good at business.
- [Roberto] That pretty much sums it up.
But, beyond--
(audience laughs)
- I mean the biggest
vulnerability Roberto,
is that some people are
such extreme just artists
that they don't have the humility
in the face of entrepreneurship being cool
to team up and have a partner
who can drive the actual business.
- [Roberto] So ultimately your answer is,
they need to either want
to invest some time again
getting this if they have the potential
that they haven't tapped.
Or outsourcing because it's weakness.
- You know me well, we've
known each other a long time.
I only think that I can get
only incrementally better
at swimming, and singing and painting.
Entrepreneurship is so cool right now,
and such a pedestal, and
has no cost of entry.
Every person here can
put the word entrepreneur
in their Instagram profile.
I'm aware.
And there's just a fundamental difference
between a successful entrepreneur
and somebody who says they are.
And there's a lot of people here
that are unbelievable creatives,
who will lose because they're
spending disproportionate time
trying to be good at something
that will never happen.
Instead of putting 100% of their effort
in the creative process.
The fact that we're blending--
Listen, there's people like Shonduras,
who is absolutely, and the reason I
attach to him and always
give him mentorship.
I'm like cool, this guy's
creative and an entrepreneur.
But there's a lot of people in here
who want to be an entrepreneur.
And there's a lot of entrepreneurs in here
that want to be a creator.
And that is the vulnerability.
The lack of self-awareness,
and the utter delusion in what they want
instead of what is real.
- [Roberto] Boom.
(audience laughs)
Thanks Gary.
- Great to see you.
- Hi Gary.
- Hi.
- I'm Sarah Beth, from Sarah Beth Yoga,
and I used to be all about that hustle.
I used to work 80 hour weeks,
and happily would work 80 hour weeks.
So I guess my issue now is that,
so I have a kid and I
have another on the way,
and so I'm much more focused
on my time management.
Earlier you mentioned like, you know,
"When you say you don't have time."
Like, I don't really
have the time anymore.
So I was purposeful
about staying on YouTube
and Facebook and Instagram.
- [Gary] I get it.
- But I hear you about expanding my brand,
and reaching out to other platforms.
How?
- Look I think, I'm very empathetic.
Look, even if you're the
greatest hustler that ever lived,
I don't know if you've heard,
it's still only 24 hours in a day, right?
So, here's what I would say Sarah.
I would say that there's
nothing wrong with staying deep
on Facebook and Google platforms.
Facebook and Google
rule the digital world.
And, there's nothing even remotely close
that's happening that is
gonna change that narrative
for the next 24 to 48
months intuitively, right?
In a world where you
have your second coming,
and all those things that
are going on in your life,
I'm not so desperate for you to have to
do other things right now.
Knowing that Instagram,
Facebook and YouTube
are going nowhere fast, right?
- [Sarah] Right.
- I think when I say to a
lot of people in this room,
you know, find more time.
As long as your ambition is
in check to your actions,
you're good, right?
You wanna be the best mom you can be,
you wanna be a creator, you
wanna be an entrepreneur.
That's awesome.
The biggest rub that I have is
you have a lot of people saying
that they're gonna build
billion dollar empires
and they're working nine hours a day.
And that's not gonna map.
Right?
So it's not that I want
you to spend more time.
As long you're like, hey,
my ambition is to make--
It's hard if you're gonna mother
and not outsource that
to a full time nanny
to have the time and energy
to build $100 million media
company around yourself.
It's gonna be hard.
As long as you're cool
and understand like hey,
maybe that's a million
instead of $100 million.
Because rightfully, you're
choosing to allocate
raising your wonderful
children, then you're good.
It's the delusion that I'm worried about.
It's that people's mouths are
way ahead of their actions.
Got it?
- [Sarah] Yeah, thank you.
- You're welcome.
- Hey Gary.
- Hey bro.
- How's your day been?
- Doing really good CJ, how are you?
- I'm good.
Okay, so I just turned 13.
I've been doing YouTube
for about two years.
And the first year I didn't
really get anything done.
But up until this summer--
- [Gary] Get anything done
as in didn't get traction?
Or you were bullshitting
playing video games?
Both of them.
- Both of them.
(audience laughs)
- But then this summer, I
started to get more like,
I quit video games and
I got a better view time
and attraction, but I'm still
like, I'm at 142 right now.
So I'm wondering like,
what's one tip you have for kids my age?
- [Gary] 142 meaning what?
- 142 subs.
- Got it, so what do
you want to happen CJ?
- I just want to get at least
300 by the end of the year.
- Okay, well first of all,
we'll take care of that.
(audience laughs)
Right?
So like, now what?
- [CJ] Just to inspire people.
- Good, so if you want to inspire people,
that's real, right?
If that's really what you're about?
Then you don't need to do anything
but continue to put out the content
that you think will do that.
- [CJ] Thank you.
- I think the reason I said like,
we'll take care of that,
is what I don't want you to
do that so many people do,
whether they're 13 or 81.
So many people get into the rat race
of how many followers they have.
Right?
And like, that's just not
the game that you wanna play.
You know what I mean?
Because, the reality is is that,
that's gonna dictate too many actions.
You can't let your
self-esteem or self-worth
be wrapped up into metrics on YouTube.
Because it's one tiny proxy
in the reality of what you're up to.
You understand?
- [CJ] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
(audience applauds)
Yeah, we're gonna throw
a right hook right now.
What's the name of your channel CJ?
- CJ Boling.
- [Gary] Spell it.
C-J-B-O-L-I-N-G.
- Slower, 'cause you want them
to actually fuckin' follow you.
(audience laughs)
- C-J-B-O-L-I-N-G.
- [Gary] B-O-L-I-N-G?
It would really mean a whole lot to me,
if I've given you one inch
of value ever in my life
for you to follow this kid.
Let's see how many
followers he has on YouTube
by the end of this weekend.
- [Woman] Can he get a picture?
- Yeah, get in here CJ.
Come here.
(audience applauds)
Good luck brother.
Hey, I've only got a couple more minutes
just trying to be fair
to the people in line.
I'm not sure if I'm gonna
be able to get to you,
but we'll see how long
they let me sit up here.
Go ahead my man.
- Hi Gary.
- Hey Devon.
- I'm one of the 99 or 100% of the people
that before today my wife
has been beating me up
to listen to you just once.
I kept--
- [Gary] Fighting it.
- Yes, I kept fighting it.
- [Gary] You're like, fuck that guy.
I get it, I get it.
I know how you roll Devon.
- And she tells me that
I think she's rude to me,
I should wait until I meet you.
That you're gonna beat it up for me.
I wanna ask you, I'm finally
drawn into what she's doing.
I want to know what I need
to do to stay on focus,
on track, and stay motivated,
you know, everyday.
- To me, generally?
- Yes she blogs about food.
She develops food recipes, and everything.
- But you're asking for
you, how you stay focused?
- Yes.
- Listen, some of you
have heard this from me.
This is such a big one for me.
I've said it in a funny setting,
and I've said it other times.
I just really wish people
knew that they were gonna die.
Devon like, how can
you not stay motivated?
Do you know that the odds
of becoming a human being
are 400 trillion to one?
- [Devon] No (laughs).
- Well great, sit on
that shit for a minute.
Like, we are so unbelievably
lacking perspective
and are so not grateful
for what's happening here.
We so focus on negativity,
and shit that's bothering us.
We need to spend way
more time on optimism,
and good, and all the good
things that are happening.
That will motivate--
I am completely driven by gratitude.
Every true day that I don't
get a text or phone call
that somebody I love died,
or has terminal illness,
I'm fuckin' pumped.
So, it's perspective Dev.
Like, the fuck do you
have to complain about?
- No I don't complain, I wanna make sure
I'm moving from the
industry that I was in,
into what she's doing,
because she has become very successful.
- It's regret man.
You don't wanna be 80 sitting and saying,
"Fuck I spoke to Gary, my
wife did it, this happened,
"and I didn't do shit.
"What the fuck?"
Listen, I'm gonna give
you guys a huge, huge,
unbelievable hack.
One day, one hour, go and
volunteer in a nursing home.
It is the great move that
everybody here can do.
First of all, it's just nice to do that.
And you give back, and it's tremendous.
And it's unbelievably impactful.
Number two, thank you, number two,
you will get way more, because
you're gonna see something
that you haven't seen
in such a pure state.
It's called regret.
You will face regret in a
way that will fuck with you
so hard that you will
stay focused and on track
for the rest of your fuckin' life.
The number one thing that you will taste,
if you go to a nursing home,
is you will find multiple people
that will talk to you about regrets
in a way that will pierce your soul.
In a way that you've never felt before.
Because they're actually in that place
where time has run out.
And it will make you go back home,
and start cooking for the first time,
starting a video, running.
Like you'll start doing shit,
that you've been pondering
for the last decade
after one hour of giving back.
Putting karma points in the bag,
and it will be hugely beneficial for you.
So please, please, please consider that.
- [Devon] Thank you so very much.
- You're welcome.
(audience applauds)
- Alright Gary, regrets,
we don't wanna have 'em.
We have two more days of VidSummit.
Almost a full more day here.
I still gotta speak, so like,
you know I'll wrap up all
the big important stuff
after you're done.
But, what should these guys
be doing for the next 48 hours
so they don't have regrets?
- That's a great question.
So, the reason I think
these things are good,
have nothing to do with
the content of this stage.
This is the number one time
to start putting your
introvert self on the shelf,
to expand your ability to network.
This is 100% ROI successful for you
if you legitimately go up to people
you've never seen before in your life,
say hello, and ask them
what they're about.
This is only about networking.
Like, you should actually all leave,
and come to none of the
talks going forward.
(audience laughs)
- Except for mine.
- Including his, and
network the whole time.
Guys, all the real magic is you know,
with the best talk of the conference,
with the third best
talk of the conference.
(audience laughs)
All of that stuff, is
so stunningly secondary,
to you getting five to seven,
to 15 relationships here.
And let me tell you something,
karma is practical.
I just said it in my last little thing,
doing the right thing for CJ.
It's just super smart to do shit
that has no expectation in
return, or anything to do--
We're in a world where a lot
of thoughts of collaborations
and things you do, you're thinking about
what comes to you after you do.
Giving without expectation has been
one of the core pillars of my success.
You've lived it.
- [Man] Love it, there it is.
- Like it's a big fuckin' deal.
Please do it.
- I'm gonna share with you
guys one pro-tip I have.
I go to a million of these conferences
and talk to so many people.
Networked until I became
friends with Gary,
and this is how I did it.
When you go to a conference,
you don't hang out with your friends,
the people that live in
your state, anyone else.
You talk to as many people
you've never met before,
and here's the theme,
this is gonna be weird,
because I probably talked
to you guys yesterday
and this exact same thing happened.
Where it's like, "Hey, how are you?
"What do you do? What's your jam?
"Learn about you, that's so cool."
Like, get a good read on someone,
become friends, follow
'em on Twitter, whatever,
and then it's, "Dang is
there food around here?
"I'm lookin' for food right now."
Literally go around looking for food,
talking to people.
Five minute conversation, become friends.
Then go look for food.
"Oh I need to go get a
drink, where's Holiday at?"
And you go talk to someone else.
Get that five minute friendship in,
and then, "Oh man, so I've
been looking for food.
"Is there food around?"
And then you walk off looking for food.
Then go get that next conversation.
Like, everyone.
I want everyone to end
their conversation with,
"I'm looking for food."
Then go talk to someone new.
Talk to everyone in this conference
'cause VidSummit 2017 is lit.
I'm not gonna dab.
Alright, that's that guys.
Have a great lunch, go find
food, talk to everyone.
- Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- I don't know how this became my life,
but D-Rock just woke
me up on a text saying
we need a question of
the day for the vlog so,
A. Fuck me,
B. Question of the day.
What are you trying to
be an influencer for?
Or what you trying to
accomplish with the attention
that you're trying to amount for yourself
or your business?
Answer me that.
(rock music)